Albert,
one thing you said to me early on in the campaign is actually pre-campaign. Um,
but you said something like the Swiss had to run a referendum on women's right.
To vote 16 times before it passed or something along those lines.
And you're you, and you made that comparison because you were like,
we should start running out of UBI now with the thought that it might take more
than one try. Uh, and I remember hearing this and I just loved the, um,
the long-term thinking you had where it wasn't like, Hey,
it's Andrew Yang going to be in the white house. It was more like, Hey, let's,
let's get the first run it because it might take multiple tries.
Yeah. It, it might be worth zooming out for a moment. Um,
you know, the, the, the UBI isn't a panacea, um,
it is one ingredient in a larger transition.
And what is that larger transition?
It's the transition out of the industrial age?
So the biggest mistake that politicians, um,
in many countries, not just the U S have been making for probably the last 10,
maybe the last 20 years is to treat digital technology and
computers as if it was just an extension of the industrial age. Um,
this transition that we're going through is as profound as when we went from
being fortress to occurrence society and then from a grand society to industrial
society.
And so those transitions took long periods of time.
Um, and they were multi-generational projects and they require it the wholesale
reinvention of how people live. Uh, and so, um,
UBI is super important. It's a cornerstone,
but it's not the only thing that we need to think about when we talk about how
we get past the industrial age. Uh, and so, um,
it's crucial to have a larger vision, uh, and you know,
part of the, um,
how we wind up with certain sort of regressive political movements at the
moment in many, um,
democracies is because we've left this vacuum where for a decade
or more, we've been saying, look, a little tweak of the interest rate here,
and a little bit of free training over there,
and everything will be good and where most people sit, that's just not true.
Most people saying that you keep saying that, but it's just not working. Right.
And so we, we, we need to paint a broader picture of a future.
Uh, and Susan mentioned the spark of Hudson earlier.
That is also part of that broader picture, which is,
who has access to knowledge? How do you bring knowledge to everybody,
including people who've been excluded from it for a long period of time?
Yeah. So that's why we're working on the workforce development program.
We're working on trying to get the infrastructure and Hudson, um,
up to speed and transportation so that people can actually get to the work, um,
that, that there may exist. So all the different parts.
And, and, and also the, the connectivity infrastructure.
So people have high-speed access, um, and fundamentally changing,
you know, where and how you can learn, right? So, um,
we have set up a system where the presumption is that you need to go to school
in order to learn.
And then ideally you go from school to some like fancy college.
And if you don't do that, you somehow, like not smart,
not worthy, can't learn things. And we believe that,
um, that's just not true that, um, people can learn things.
They can learn them at different ages in different ways. And that, you know,
a big thrust of digital technology is to let people learn things at any point.
Um, you know, including much later in life.
Now, more than ever, not your kids, again are a bit older,
but I was in parts of the country where they don't have high speed internet.
And you can imagine those kids now trying to learn. I mean,
there are so many kids that right now are struggling,
uh, academically because of the fact that now, I mean,
they've lost months and we're looking at this fall,
it's unclear what school's going to look like.
But certainly having broadband access to me is like a cornerstone,
a building block. It's like,
how can you make meaningful educational opportunities available if someone like
they're not even going to be able to plug in, uh, uh, in a real way.
So one thing that you all have been very passionate about,
which I think most everyone listening to this is going to agree with is that,
so you have one, cornerstone is universal, basic income,
and then climate change is something else that you've been very passionate about
and working on. And so, Susan,
I'd love to ask you something that I just saw an article,
and it made me almost jumped for joy where someone who's an environmental
activists said, Hey, universal,
basic income might really be part of the solution, um,
lighting up our environmental footprint. Uh,
so can you talk about the work you all have been doing on climate change and how
you see some of these income policies impacting our ability to make
progress on a sustainable economy?
The relation to UBI is a really interesting one. Um, first, uh,
as we talked about previously,
we'll let more people be politically active and get to solutions, um,
for the climate crisis. But the second thing is there's also some evidence, um,
early evidence that UBI changes people's view of consumption.
Um, and the way it does that is that when you are no longer in the
scarcity mindset that, um, Oh my God, I can't afford anything.
Our consumption actually starts to loom less large and people's, um,
needs and, and all of a sudden people go, Oh,
maybe I should learn something instead.
Or maybe I should put some money aside, or maybe I should, um,
become engaged in something. So, um, there's a lot of evidence that, um,
this sort of scarcity mindset that is forced upon a lot of people makes it very
difficult to think beyond consumption and so much of,
um, uh, what we're applying ourselves to unfortunately is just, you know,
consumption and it's just making enough money to keep consuming.
And so districts.
And to pay the bills, put food on the table, right? Yeah.
So disrupting that is a, is a crucial aspect. I made this.
Same argument on the trail.
One of my hopes was that if you have the boot off of people's
throats, where you had enough money, where you could meet your basic needs,
I thought we'd have much more in the way of arts and creativity and folks going
to the woods and working on a novel and whatnot,
and adopting more minimalist type lifestyles,
because they would have different goals for themselves in different pursuits
instead of driving and commuting to their cubicle and doing job X,
like you'd have more people doing things that were more organic.
Now and that with COVID right,
a lot of people are now moving to the country and we're seeing that they're not
consuming as much as they were that they're going out in nature that they're
enjoying it. That they're, that they're doing activities that as Albert said,
is, are not consumptive.
And there's a basic income project in Germany that Susan,
that I've been supporting for years,
that has a lot of evidence to that same effect where people, um, really,
um, suddenly decrease the consumption. This is sometimes a, uh,
an objection that people bring up to UBI.
They say people just going to spend it on more stuff,
but actually the evidence goes the opposite direction.
That makes me so glad because I was making that argument on the trail probably
best. I wasn't citing like some German data. Oh,
that's American said to like their data homegrown. But, uh, like the,
the thing I was suggesting was like, look,
if you can actually get the boot off of people's throats,
they're going to be much more energized around making different types of choices
and also be more, uh, attentive to climate change. Because right now,
if you were laboring under this constant scarcity mindset, and someone says,
you need to worry about climate change. And you're like,
I'm worried about next month rent. You know, it's like, like, like,
like the earth or this big grand problem, that's a years away.
And then the human impulse is to say as a diabetic,
it's not that big a deal anyway,
like this is like the sort of a defensive response.
Well, and also, um,
the thing that we're working on here at the farm is we're trying to change the
mindset of how people view the climate crisis that, you know,
it could really be. Um, when you, when you work to be sustainable,
it can really be something quite joyous where it's all around sort of enjoying
nature. And.
Yeah, I mean, it's, it's the idea that, um,
we have the means to overcome this crisis without somehow all, you know,
going back and sort of living in a hovel, right.
And being dour about it. We're having fun while we're doing it.